muy buenas tardes a todos cómo están
listos
[Aplausos]
a esa empresa que seguramente muchos de
nosotros admiramos y que revolucionó
entre otras cosas la industria de la
música digital y que nos cambió para
siempre la manera que escuchamos música
seguramente muchos de ustedes tienen
aparatos como estos es así
bueno esa empresa ha perdido su negocio
la velocidad del cambio como está
ocurriendo hoy en la comunidad
empresarial está dejando fuera del
mercado incluso a empresas de este
tamaño antes las empresas grandes se
comían las empresas pequeñas hoy las
empresas veloces se están comiendo las
empresas que son más lentas
sorprende el sorprender
vivimos en tiempos de cambios violentos
y sin previo aviso con cosas creo que
muy buenas por ejemplo hay una
aplicación que seguro útil ustedes
utilizan que llama ways que nos permite
llegar en lugares complicados a lugares
y llegar más rápido
otro que me encantó para contarles hay
un dispositivo que te puedes poner en tu
hombro con tu brazo que dura 15 días y
mide tu cosa y manda la información a tu
dispositivo y entonces a tu médico
bastante útil si eres un paciente de
diabetes si no tienes que pinchar de
tres veces por día
hay otras que creo que son un poco más
complicadas y que nos pueden poner a
temblar en la forma en la que vivimos
día a día en nuestras expectativas
también nuestros negocios
y déjenme contarles una historia para
ilustrar esto esto no por favor todavía
el 2001 apple inventó el negocio de la
música digital legal con su plataforma
itunes seguramente muchos de ustedes han
comprado música de esa manera
un super negocio funcionó muy bien
personalmente a mí me tocó trabajar con
una disquera independiente mexicana y
acompañarla en ese camino de pasar de
vender esas cosas redondas se acuerdan
cómo llamaban eso a vender archivos
digitales esto fue todo un desafío tuve
que aprender muchas cosas fue un súper
negocio
en algún momento de la historia
alrededor del 2008 nació un pequeño
start-up en un lugar bastante remoto
suecia
interesante es que proponía un cambio de
modelo
sobre todo el modelo de consumo en vez
de pagar para tener algo y vas a pagar
para tener acceso a algo
además en vez de almacenar los datos en
tus dispositivos los datos pasaban por
tus dispositivos expiraban se llama
streaming
lo interesante es que en 34 años esta
empresa se quedó con entre el 75 y el 80
por ciento del mercado mundial saben
cómo se llama no
exactamente siempre se llama spotify
imaginen la cara de tim cook cuando ese
tsunami le pasó por encima la imaginan
yo digo cómo es que esta empresa tan
grande la segunda empresa más valuada
del mundo no la vio venir y perdió su
negocio
awlaki y ahora es exento de que te pase
lo mismo
es tú spotify
este tiempo trabajando con
organizaciones o líderes de las
organizaciones en más de 10 países me
pusieron a pensar ya reflexionar
y en contra una terrible conclusión
es que en parte culpable de esta muerte
silenciosa de las organizaciones es la
creencia que tiene muchos de estos
líderes y que es la siguiente si quieres
toma nota porque vale la pena y es para
qué debería cambiar si ahora me va bien
-aquellos debería cambiar si ahora me va
bien
es para pensarlo y yo digo entonces por
esto ya no basta con saber gestionar el
cambio si quieres tener un futuro que
eliges un futuro que quieres desarrollar
un futuro que quieres vivir
quieres renacer
entonces tienes que inventar tu futuro
diseñar cómo va a ser y luego liderar lo
para que se convierta en realidad
lo que le estoy diciendo no es teoría
la reina si varias veces incluso en otro
país
el cual ustedes son mis huéspedes
ok y voy a hacer un ejercicio con
ustedes espero que colaboren conmigo
piensa muy rápido y dime en porcentaje
qué porcentaje de tu tiempo de tu vida
normal estás en conversaciones del
pasado
los 120
30 cuantos 40
5 por ahí atrás no se escucha nada
podríamos poner como promedio de sala
como un 40 habían de acuerdo
las conversaciones del pasado
generalmente son dos una de las
conversaciones del pasado tiene que ver
con la melancolía con recordar un tiempo
que ya no regresa algo que viví en el
pasado que no va a volver
el otro tipo de conversación del pasado
tiene que ver con algo que no pude
resolver en el pasado algo que no me
gusta que sucedió en el pasado y sigo
resintiendo en el presente
ahora otra vez en porcentaje qué
porcentaje de tu tiempo de tu día
estas son conversaciones del futuro
60 40 84 60
máspero y otras
50 podríamos decir que están más o menos
cerca de 60 por ciento
en general esta conversación del futuro
que tienes es una conversión
especulativa si sucede esto voy a hacer
esta otra cosa y me dice esto le voy a
decir esta otra cosa y que te genera eso
en el cuerpo
ansiedad angustia no y esto es
interesante porque es lo que aprendí
viajando por latinoamérica es que en
cada cultura les pega o nos pega en el
cuerpo de una manera diferente personas
y les digo que en méxico y mucha
politice o gastritis bueno en colombia
por ejemplo se dan muchas jaquecas
en argentina a la gente se queda en la
cama ok entonces mi pregunta es la
siguiente si la mitad del tiempo me
dijiste que el 40 por ciento estás en el
pasado y el 60 por ciento de tu tiempo
estás en el futuro cuando estás en el
presente
ahora sí les voy a decir que hay en el
segundo tipo de conversación del futuro
que tiene que ver no con preocuparme del
futuro sino con ocuparme
y esa es la conversación en la que
quiero que centremos al resto de esta
plática
y estás aquí en el presente correcto y
si sigues haciendo lo mismo que estás
haciendo de la misma manera vas a llegar
a un futuro probable
un señor muy inteligente que diosa no
nombraron antes que llamaba a albert
einstein decía locura es hacer una y
otra vez la misma cosa esperando obtener
un resultado diferente
somos super especialistas los seres
humanos en esto
y puede que esto funcione pero puede que
no que aparezca tu spotify y te vayas a
un futuro que no deseas ese futuro donde
no vas a pasar muy bien
entonces que nos queda y de eso
estábamos hablando en vez de
preocuparnos del futuro en vez de
reaccionar a las circunstancias nos
ocupemos de inventar diseñar y luego
liderar el futuro entonces en algún
momento de tu vida tendrás que hacer
algo diferente para conseguir ese futuro
que deseas lo que yo llamo para empezar
esto la oportunidad única
y quiere decir la oportunidad única que
hay una única oportunidad no lo que digo
es que tú puedes generar una oportunidad
única para ti si me permiten con un
ejemplo les voy a contar un poco esta
historia
es oportunidad única
pero porque depende de un contexto de un
tiempo y un espacio único y además como
tercer elemento como ven ahí el ojito
es en tu mirada es tu oportunidad única
de explicar con un ejemplo vamos vamos
con otros profesores para atrás por
favor
y hay que contar la historia que ocurre
con dos emprendedores que se llaman
adame miguel new york' del 2010 imagina
en ese contexto hubo una mega explosión
económica en eeuu en el 2008 que va
avanzando y estamos en 2010
lo que ven como problema del cual se
quieren hacer cargo es primero hay un
montón de edificios vacíos porque porque
quebraron un montón de empresas se
acuerdan de toda esa historia segundo
hay mucha gente que se quedó sin trabajo
y empiezan a hacer freelancers empiezan
a hacer pequeños emprendimientos
startups
incipientes y además y sobre todo los
siguientes que van a ver acá que es que
hay una gran gran gran crisis de valores
afecta a todo lo demás
adam y miel se quieren hacer cargo de
este problema
empiezan a pensar cuáles son nuestras
experiencias de vida cuáles son nuestras
fortalezas para hacernos cargo de esto y
lo que se dan cuenta es adam se había
quebrado un negocio llamamos crawlers en
brooklyn de productos para bebés pero
había aprendido un montón y había
conocido mucha gente
luego se juntó con miel habían hecho un
pequeño emprendimiento emprendimiento
llamaba green desk
rentas de oficinas en new york
además
es israelí y viene una mentalidad muy
startup en la cual se educa a la gente
porque además llega al lugar determinado
el ejército llega con una mentalidad muy
desarrollada a aprender del error a que
te equivoques muchas veces para que
entonces luego emprendas muchas más
herramientas hoy incluso si prendan a
cualquier jefe hunter un a un ejecutivo
que ya se equivocó se equivocó muchas
veces es mucho más valorado el industria
que ya el aprendizaje lo pago otra
empresa y además juntos se pusieron de
acuerdo en cuáles sí que van a ser esos
valores sobre los cuales se apoyaban
entonces tenían claro sobre qué
problemas que no hacerse cargo y quiénes
eran ellos en ese tiempo y espacio con
su mirada que construye en esta
oportunidad ahora en vez de mirarse al
ombligo empezaron a mirar para fuera con
lo cual lo que se dieron cuenta es vamos
a ver cuáles son las amenazas que hay lo
que encontraron como amenazas para
ponerse a cuánto es estamos en una mega
crisis económica esto significa que no
hay qué
pero es que la gente está un poco
alineada entonces lo que había también
es una gran falta de innovación al no
haber dinero lo que no hay es innovación
pero por sobre todo el tejido social
está de construido de por sí en la
cultura estadounidense donde la gente es
bastante individualista sabía todavía
exponenciado esta conducta
de todo esto lo que deciden es construir
una solución un negocio una oportunidad
única un futuro que ofrecía las
siguientes cosas por ejemplo en este
espacio de trabajo en conjunto que no
tengas que ir hacer una inversión
inicial para poder empezar a trabajar o
sea que sea un producto llave en mano
además puedas crecer y achicar te cuando
lo necesites en base a cómo funciona tu
negocio y el mercado además decidieron
que como nos íbamos a hacer cargo de
todos esos freelancers y startups
empiezan a hacer cosas pero le falta le
falta desarrollo le faltó apoyo y
crearon un lado un laboratorio para
apoyar a los startups pero por sobre
todo el lugar lo han vuelto o lo
volvieron aspiracional fashion y como un
espacio de encuentro donde volvamos a
trabajar
ese tejido social de las personas
vuelvan a hablarse a mirarse a los ojos
no podemos compartir no solo una mirada
sino también un café
y esto seguramente saben cómo se llama
no se los cuento esta oportunidad única
se llama work
y hoy está en todo el mundo o sea que
creo que le funcionó
entonces está acá
esta es una metodología no quiere decir
que sea la verdad pero se la ofrezco a
ustedes para que empiecen a crear su
oportunidad única porque una es que has
empezado a crear tu futuro entonces
también te ofrezco una idea de poder
seguir los siguientes seis pasos para
inventar diseñar liderar tu futuro
el siguiente paso después que ya has
creado tu oportunidad única y recuerden
que no es la única oportunidad de
esperar muchas oportunidades únicas
una vez que eso está listo está listo
para empezar a declarar tu visión
es la diferencia entre la visión y un
sueño
ocurre algo
única diferencia entre una visión y un
sueño son acciones y compromiso con lo
que dices que quieres
lo hice me gustaría y te quedas en tu
casa sentado en el sillón
a pasar
cuando te comprometes con lo que quieres
y declaras la visión porque esa visión
tiene que ser declarada por el líder que
lleva este producto esta idea esta
pasión que vas a poner adelante no
cambia nada en tu realidad lo que cambia
es tu relación con tu presente porque
entonces en vez de estar durmiendo en tu
sillón estás actuando coherentemente con
lo que dices que quieres accionando para
que eso suceda
el tercer paso
para avanzar entonces en tu diseño de
futuro tiene que ver con entender
quiénes son esas personas relevantes e
influyentes los cuales depende que tú
involucres de alguna manera para que
esto suceda
lo cual tendrás que entender quiénes son
y hacer tu estrategia de cómo vas e
involucrarlos en este proceso de
peticiones ofertas y conversaciones que
están faltando y qué tipo de relación
tienes con cada uno y tengas que
trabajar para entonces irnos al cuarto
paso el cuarto paso tiene que ver con
construir ahora fíjense que dice retro
plan no dice plan los invito a pensar al
revés a venir desde el futuro hacia el
presente
que tiene que estar pasando en diciembre
que tiene que estar pasando en noviembre
que tiene que estar pasando en octubre
y ahí hasta el presente porque entonces
lo que nos permite ver es que está
faltando en cada momento y no solo que
está faltando sino que cosas tengo que
aprender
en cada momento yo mi equipo para que
eso suceda entonces el siguiente paso
tiene que ver con aprender y además
pedir tener claridad de cómo voy a estar
midiendo dónde estoy en relación a mi
visión pueden ser indicadores duros como
un café pero también tiene que ver con
medir comportamientos lo que llamamos
cabello
y comportamiento quiero modelar en
y estructura en mi equipo para lograr
esa visión y así el siguiente paso es
aprender aprender aprender aprender
aprender y seguir aprendiendo porque el
día que dejas de aprender que te moriste
y entonces una vez que has logrado todo
esto que ha moldeado de los
comportamientos que quieres para tu
visión para tu equipo para tu futuro vas
a dedicar entonces a liderar a las
personas a que te acompañen en esa
visión
y hoy se habla mucho de felicidad y hay
mucho de eso en ese camino disfrutar el
camino al destino
entonces
la década
la que tim cook siguió al mando de apple
para que el 2015 a pre reacciona sacando
un producto llamada music que hace
exactamente lo mismo que el otro no han
logrado posicionarse otra vez como reyes
del juego y quién sabe si lo vuelvan a
hacer alguna vez
lo que estoy seguro es que las cosas van
a seguir cambiando
probablemente muchísimo más rápido cada
vez
así que te digo
hoy aquí tienes la maravillosa
maravillosa oportunidad de inventar tu
futuro y diseñarlo como quieres y luego
entonces liderarlo para que software
ahora mientras el tiempo sigue corriendo
john lennon decía la vida es eso qué
sucede mientras estás ocupado pensando
en otra cosa
así que te desafío a que actúes aquí
ahora y diseñe es tu futuro o elijas ser
parte del futuro de alguien más
[Aplausos]